-This will be cake compared to
what we did earlier.
That was insane for me.
-It's so scary.
I never thought that
I was a nervous person,
but it turns out I really am
because that is terrifying.
-It's terrifying, and when you
feel heat coming off
of something, I knew it was
alive or something was there,
but then I go -- I thought
maybe it was our chemistry.
-Well, it could have been that
because it really got me going
when you were doing
that great little dance.
[ Laughter ]
-That was a frightened dance.
I'm so happy you're here,
and I'm so happy to see you.
You know, the last time I saw
you, you were pregnant with
Harper, who is now 10 years old.
-And you don't look a day older.
-Yeah, right.
[ Laughter ]
-You do not.
-Stop it.
[ Laughter ]
How is the family?
How is everybody?
-They're so good.
They're so good.
-Well, you, obviously, a global
superstar with Spice Girls.
You take Spice Girls.
You start your own fashion line.
Again, global success. Congrats.
-Thank you.
-That's a tough jump,
by the way.
I know you were Posh
and everything, but still --
[ Laughter ]
-Do you know,
I just feel so lucky
to have these creative outlets.
You know, it's what
I love to do.
I love fashion. I love beauty.
You know, I just love
to make women feel like
the best version of themselves,
and to be able to do that
through fashion --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do. I really, really do.
If somebody wants to
invest in my brand,
wear my clothes or my makeup,
that's why I'm doing it.
I want women to feel great
about themselves.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you remember the first time
you saw someone wearing
something from your line where
you're like, "Wow, I made that"?
-Yeah, I think I was in
a restaurant with my husband.
And I always like to compliment
women anyway, you know,
even if they're not wearing
something of mine
just because I always think
that's really important.
And I was just so excited.
I mean, it's great seeing
anybody wear your clothes,
you know, not just celebrities
on the red carpet,
but anybody that wants to
wear my stuff.
And it's very ex-- It's probably
really uncool actually.
I really just want to clap
or something.
-Do you go around and just clap
and go, "I love it.
I'm so excited"?
-Yeah.
-I have some photos
I want to show you,
because when you and
David Beckham started dating,
you guys wore kind of
matching outfits a lot.
I don't know if you did this
on purpose.
[ Laughter ]
Do you remember?
I mean -- I mean -- Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-We have been known to. I mean,
we didn't do it that much.
But every time we did,
it was very well-documented
and just will not leave me
alone, let me tell you.
-It follows you around, yeah.
-It really does.
-But why did you do it? Because
you were just young and in love?
-It just seemed like a really
good idea at the time, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-To wear matching outfits
together?
-It really did.
I think it was a naivete then.
We didn't know about fashion.
We were just having fun with it,
which, to be honest with you,
is kind of the way it should be.
I really wish I had the courage
to do it more now.
-Yeah. Do you feel like
that's been kind of
taken away a little bit
from you?
-I suppose the more that
you get to know the industry
and the older that you get,
you know, the less naive.
I mean, we didn't know,
we didn't care.
We just had fun,
and we were like,
"Hey, let's wear
matching leather."
[ Laughter ]
And we did.
-Yeah, you definitely did.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, they like it.
I think you should --
Just explain this situation.
-You forget, right?
-I mean, you're both knockout,
drop-dead-gorgeous-looking
people.
So it doesn't matter what
you're really wearing.
If I wore that,
I wouldn't look like that.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, we were actually
just on a country walk.
And yeah.
-I want to go on a country walk.
-You should try that outfit,
Jimmy.
I think it could really work
on you.
-But you've taken this now,
and then you got into
Victoria Beckham Beauty.
-Yes.
-Which has also taken off.
And I know,
from having interviewed people,
how hard this business is,
how many years go into
making something like this.
It's very difficult
to take off and launch.
And you did it. Congratulations.
-Thank you. Yeah, it's been
a passion of mine and was
a big dream of mine to
really focus on clean beauty.
So beauty formulas and packaging
that are clean,
but, you know, products that
are the ultimate in luxury
at an affordable luxury
price point,
products that really work,
products that I've never been
able to find in my makeup bag.
And I'm a bit obsessed with
makeup.
-You are, yeah?
-And also making sure
it's inclusive so that you can
find the perfect products
no matter what skin tone
you have, is really key.
So, inclusivity, clean beauty,
but the ultimate in luxury.
That was my goal,
and I saw a space in the market
where nobody else was doing
that, and it's going very well.
-Good for you.
-Thank you.
-And you did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy to see you again.
Congrats on
your beautiful family.
-Thank you so much.
-Best to everyone.
Victoria Beckham, everyone.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-For more info on
her beauty line,
go to victoriabeckhambeauty.com.